ابو حسينت
انا شويه للاسف بالغلط في المصافيت
عليك شويه
حد
[Arabic recitation]
اياك تدعي علي وانت بتزرشخير
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان
لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
ك الوجيز يقول المؤلف وجوب الاقتصاد في
ماء الوضوء وحرمه الاسراف فيه
[Silence]
and the mentions this here ‏is that
being that we have already
discussed the conditions of weve already
discussed the obligations of wu weve
already discussed the sun of w the
preferred encouraged aspects of now we
after we have built up
an act of worship
now that we understand how to build it
we're going to understand and we're
going to learn how to protect it ‏So the
author goes then into traditionally the
authors then usually follow this up with
the things that invalidate
right and while this
that he going to mention doesn't
necessarily invalidate
it is something that is imperm
during making
the
‏theation
of
being economical inراف
[Silence]
انه لا يحب المسرفين
بتين الاسراف والتبذير
قران
الله سبحانه وتعالى ولا تسرفوا انه لا يحب
المسرفين
انز ان المبذرين كانوا اخوان الشياطين
وكان الشيطان لربه كفورافذراف
التبذير التبذير
الاسراف
[Silence]
التبذير
الاسراف اللهبذبين
‏of
التبذير اشد في العقوبه واشد في ذكر الذم
التبذير اشد من الاسراف فما الفرق الفرق
بينهما
يقول العلماء الاسراف
هو الزياده
فيما يجوز الاصل فيه
او الزياده
في ما يجوز في الاصل واما التبذير
فهو اضاعه المال
فيما لا يجوز اصلا
ايش الفرق
يعني مثلا
من الجائز في الاسلام
العرس
العرس اللي نحن بنسميه العرس وفي الحقيقه
ايش؟ وليمه الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول
ايه اعلنوا النكاح واضربوا عليه بالدف
ماشي اذا الوليمه الاصل فيه انه جائز بذل
المال في الوليمه ولا غير جائز؟
[Arabic recitation]
لكن لما الانسان يزيد
في
هذه الاشياء في الماكل والمشارب والفخفخه
من اجل الافتخار ومن اجل ان يكون من اهل
اهلكت مالا لبدا
ويتفاخر بين الناس الى اخره هذا اسمه ايش؟
اسراف لانه الاصل فيه جائز لكن يزيد فيه
عن الحد لكن التبذير واحد يروح يكمر مثلا
اي ال القمار نحن عننا ب بنغير القاف كاف
يكمل
واحد بروح يكمر واحد بروح اي يضيع امواله
في الخمر في الخمور في المخدرات في كذا
هذا هل يجوز الاصل في هل يجوز بذل المال
في هذا الباب لا يجوز ز اصلا اذا هذا ماذا
يسمى تبذير ان المبذرين كانوا اخوان
الشياطين لذلك يقول ال المؤلف وجوب
الاقتصاد في ماء الوضوء وحرمه الاسراف لو
قال المؤلف وحرمه التبذير هل يصح في هذا
الباب؟ لا يصح لان الاصل جواز استعمال
الماء للوضوء
وللتنظيف
وما شابه ذلك
was
صلاه يقول عن انس قال كان النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم يغسل او كان يغتسل
بالصاع الى خمسه امداد
ويتوضا بالمد والحديث متفق عليه
انس رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
غسل
وض
الله عليه
غسل
بالصاع الى خمسه امداد
[Silence]
ரin, water
handful this iser to as a
one of these handful is called a
now have
the fluid weight of
فيقول يقول
صاحب
الصحاح
رحمه الله تعالى
ان الصاع
هو
الرطل والنصف
عند اهل الشام
وهو ما يساوي الرطلين عند اهل العراق
تعرفون الرطل
يبيعون عندكم بالرطل
الرطل الرطل
الرطل
[Silence]
انس رضي الله
غسل صلى الله عليه وسلم
hands
of
would hand
would make this
م
[Silence]
‏Why? Because their b farger our b
the human being generally are smaller
and smaller as time go
the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم tellsم عليه
السلام
was
ولا يزال الخلق في تناقص
‏and people to smaller this is a way
some mention this is the reason for the
wisdom tooth problem the wisdom teeth
you know
why do we have wisdom tee why are they
infected why are they
well this is because our jaws are
getting smaller and so our jaw
‏as
to
and point is
the for him is be mucher than the is for
me but it doesn't matter exactly the
amount of his m and exactly the amount
of my m because each person's m is
proporal to his own body so if he made
غسل
[Silence]
وضو
‏wasquances
more may instances
would
ان شاء الله تعالى نسال الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان يفقهنا في ديننا وان يعلمنا وان
يستعملنا ولا يستبدلنا والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد